[Music]
so speaking of hbo shows man i did it i
did the plunge
what three episodes f boy island are you
dead i took the plunge and
it's like a bad mtv show from the 2000s
shot in 4k okay
you know
the formula is definitely there that
first episode seems so stale like in
terms of the pacing the editing
everything they have these really
bad shoehorned edits
it it feels like a youtube video yeah
and um
they have these awful scripted moments
that are supposed to be funny with that
they have the contestants like act out
and they insert modern references into
it it just feels so hard like
like millennials just trying to fit in
with zoomers somehow or or no no it's
adapting zoomer humor for
millennials okay you know it's just like
millennials will watch that and go oh my
god i know that tick tock yeah yeah
like [ __ ] dude
you're wha we're watching
a whole generation of people i wouldn't
know because i'm 16
but age themselves like in front of
everyone yeah and
you know nikki glazier is like trying to
do her best but they have her
deliver lines and stuff like whoever's
directing this it's just like ugh
she has this moment where
people are getting sent off
she goes um
like she reads out two guys names such
and such you're a nice guy
nice try oh
no blah blah blah you're a f boy f by
get out
so wait so i bring this up
because one dude gets eliminated in the
first episode or the second episode
and he
reads a poem to the girl as kind of like
a last ditch good no that's always a
good thing to do yeah girls love poetry
especially when it's
composed and read by
men that are trying to court them and
for sure the producers were like read
this you're probably going to go home
tonight but read this
and just man it just
it feels so bad really because the one i
always made a clip of that the one part
that's raw is all the contestants in the
back like all the dudes are like tearing
their hair up they're like bruh shut up
no more
what is the poem like
uh
it's just a poem okay it's a bad one
like roses are red no no no violets are
blue it's definitely sentimental i want
to eat you out
no it's
when da da da like fall to the side
that's where you find love it's
something you read at a wedding okay
really rough to hear
not not on f boy island nah the craziest
part the craziest part is that they
don't they never say boy that is so
annoying the whole time
you're just wondering this is hbo max
why is this so pg yeah are you an f-boy
you know it's hbo isn't that the point
yeah you're a boy man yeah
and or fart boy yeah far point
fart boy island so i just had some
enchiladas
dude oh man dude i feel it in my stomach
man
sorry i just have to say
this last bit is it's so over produced
in the most annoying way okay they don't
do it like love island where the 4k
shots accent the drama and it's used to
highlight character
development or whatever it's like
4k
camera dolly left of this girl eating
yogurt and then dolly wright i was like
so girls what are you feeling today and
then just up in your face 4k like you
know whatever
it's oh man it's just so try hard
it's trying as hard as we were trying to
make fun of dana white
yeah we that wasn't funny
we're just repeating what he was saying
yeah
and uh the girls as well like only one
of them really has personality
there's one guy on there who's like
self-proclaimed bitcoin investor okay
i really want to know what that means
yeah
what when you say bitcoin funny because
so many people are now yeah it's not
really like that's kind of like saying
like yeah i'm a roth ira investor yeah
most people are
what was dark was
him and this other dude
they
immediately they used their childhood
stories to like quote be vulnerable okay
in the first conversation you know like
one of them's like i was adopted with my
sister another one you know my mom
single parent i was raised alone
and
one of the dudes
goes yeah that's
he's like once they buy in that's when i
know like i got him like
she can't
you know she she can't turn away from me
now it's like that's [ __ ] up oh so
he's using like the
heart heart-wrenching story yeah to get
in her pants or whatever essentially
yeah to like get like to manipulate so
that guy is an f-boy then
yeah okay no he's a nice guy yeah
no i just i was blown away that
someone would be so
comfortable representing themselves that
way yeah then i remember oh yeah this is
like a bad mtv show but it's like what's
the point of the show is that they have
to figure out who is three girls these
guys have to so yeah they have to figure
out who the f boys are okay and like
find love or like there's a cash prize
and do you know who the nice guys are
and who the f boys are you know who some
of them are okay
like you could like with deductive
reasoning or some of them they like
proclaim it to the talking head
interview gotcha but that's the other
part is
this like the types of guys are it's so
obvious who is not an [ __ ] yeah
there's no mystery
it's not like when you find out some
guy's a f boy you're like
it's like yeah
in the first interaction he's like maybe
we could sleep in the same bed you're
like okay
yeah yeah f boy and then the nice guys
are good i love to smell your [ __ ]
sometimes yeah
then it cuts to f-boy i think he might
be an f-boy yeah
he's got f-boy written all over him
yo i'd love to [ __ ] you and the other
two girls on the same day
so if you if you would be cool dad let
me know
yeah i don't know if his intentions are
pure
it doesn't really seem like it it's like
on the bachelor when there's the one
girl who's a pure psycho and every girl
in the house goes she's crazy
i'm starting to feel like she might not
be here for the right reasons
it's just mind numbing man but the fact
that it's so overproduced you don't even
you can't even enjoy it because you're
just thinking oh the producers are just
affecting all of this yeah so i hate
that i hate over-editing that's what i
like about love island is that like it's
shot really nice but they don't
they don't do those cut those reality tv
show cuts where they're basically
creating a different conversation in the
one they're actually having yeah like
when they're like
so what do you do i like
strawberries and you're like
what do you do for work
yeah
yeah i'm a bitcoin investor
love island does do that though
sometimes i meant like the conversation
cuts i hate those yeah
you know when i cut to a laugh way too
fast
and you're like that clearly did not
happen there like you just
yeah totally fabricated that
conversation yeah
and either way i just the thing i loved
is like they made this big push to
obviously compete with all the island
shows yeah they made the worst one
[Music]
the only island show that's close to
love island is temptation island because
that is [ __ ] up
here look at this ipad watch your girl
get nailed yeah someone else that's like
one long castle more isn't it yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah i
suffered through all three yeah my
parents keep telling me to watch that
season watch an incredible show watch
season two season two will like make
your heart fall in your nutsack okay
it feels bad okay
like and it's like
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's how it
is that's how it feels that's how it
feels nice like i'm gonna sit down for
this tea
okay okay okay
straight away straight away yeah
straight
dude
we gotta make a reality show where
there's no point nothing happens there's
no goal yeah constantly the characters
are just like why are we here yeah and
we have to just be like all right today
we're doing
this you know like the potato sack race
and they're like okay
and then they win and they cheer and
there's no prize yeah you won you won
congrats guys yeah
back into the hole yeah what
okay
it just goes on for like three years
yeah it's just
it's like survivor day one
survivor
survivor months one through six
and then start the bachelor on month
seven
so we're all going to put you in suits
and she likes the idea of getting
married okay yeah that's it and then
it's american ninja warrior yeah yeah
for the last
for the start of the next year
then it's real world for the next six
the six months after that
that sounds like influencer daycare yeah
basically yeah yeah no we just want to
imprison 20 millennials yeah
and just film them
a vague hope all right you won immunity
this week
but no one ever gets voted off yeah
they're like
what's it from immunity from what just
immunity immunity congrats
you're immune
all right [ __ ]
all right guys after six weeks the
public has voted
you guys are chosen
congrats and we'll see you next week
wait chosen for what and then the music
is just rolling
in the credits chosen for what wait
you didn't tell us what we were chosen
for you've been chosen
tune in next week to see the public
choose choose for what
why us
because you're the chosen ones it's so
dark that's why they chose you if
they're in there long enough like dude
you can't please tell us you caught them
right here then at the end of the year
you've been chosen
wait what the [ __ ]
we get to leave
maybe just let them wallow for another
year
they're the only ones that were ever
chosen
they started going and saying i think
they're gonna kill us
i think they're gonna send us
over the island edge
god damned are you ready for castlemore
and they just moved to another house
yeah
why do we go to this house
it's the same
why is it it's exactly the same no it's
different
so you're gonna spend the next six
months here and someone will be chosen
okay
you